Transcription: Ilaria Marinozzi
Relecteur: eric vautier
Les prochaines élections présidentielles
sont dans un peu plus de 50 mois.
Et je dois dire que ça me réjouit.
Je déteste parler de politique.
Ou plutôt je déteste quand on m’en parle,
surtout quand c’est dans la file d’attente
d’une boulangerie ou dans un taxi.
Vous voyez, ce chauffeur,
qui ne vous connaissez pas encore
il y a quelques instants,
et qui trouve que c’est une bonne
idée de partager avec vous
ses opinions, ses projets pour la France.
Si vous retrouvez dans
ce genre de situation, fuyez.
Ne cherchez ni à débattre ni à convaincre.
Demandez au taxi de s’arrêter
et terminez votre chemin à pied.
J’ai longtemps cru qu’avec de bons
arguments, nous pouvons convaincre,
faire évoluer les opinions, ce que les
gens pensent, ce que les gens font.
Et puis j’ai compris que dans un débat,
un bon argument permet davantage
de rassurer la personne
qui est déjà convaincue
que de faire changer l’opinion
de quelqu’un qui ne l’est pas encore.
Mais j'ai mis du temps à le comprendre.
Il faut dire que ça n'a rien d'intuitif.
On nous apprend depuis que
nous sommes petits, à raisonner,
à enchaîner des idées logiques.
C'est le fondement même
de notre éducation.
On a appris que a au carré
plus b au carré égalent c au carré.
Et c'est terriblement rassurant.
Mais en matière de psychologie,
ce pragmatisme, cette logique
tant valorisée dans la société
est bien souvent inadaptée
pour comprendre les mécanismes.
Et en matière d’influence plus
particulièrement, nous devons apprendre,
aussi contre-intuitif
que cela puisse paraître,
qu’un bon argument permet
rarement de convaincre.
C’est en travaillant
dans la publicité que j’ai compris
qu’argumenter n’était pas
la manière la plus efficace
de changer les opinions
ou les comportements.
Je crois que j’ai choisi
de faire de la publicité
davantage pour comprendre les gens
que pour les influencer ou
que par amour pour les marques.
J’ai passé des heures à observer les gens,
dans la rue, dans les supermarchés,
à écouter la conversation d’à côté
quand je suis au restaurant.
J’ai passé des jours entiers
à analyser les comportements
dans des bases de données,
à comprendre les publicités
qui influençaient les Français,
à comprendre parfois
les contradictions des consommateurs.
Vous saviez par exemple qu’en France,
les consommateurs qui disent vouloir
consommer des entreprises éthiques
sont aussi ceux qui consomment davantage
Amazon, Uber ou
les entreprises de fast fashion ?
C’est quand même très étonnant,
et surtout très irrationnel.
En analysant l’efficacité de
nombreuses campagnes de publicité,
je me suis rendu compte d’une chose :
les campagnes qui reposent sur des
arguments et sur des procédés rationnels
sont bien souvent moins efficaces
que les campagnes
qui n'utilisent pas d'arguments
rationnels pour convaincre.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
On travaille depuis quelques années
pour une grande chaîne
de distribution alimentaire
pour laquelle nous devons
évidemment travailler
la perception de qualité
des fruits et légumes.
Figurez-vous que nous sommes rendu compte
d’une chose tout à fait surprenante :
lorsque nous faisons des campagnes qui
reposent sur des arguments rationnels,
sur un discours précis où on donne
des arguments, par exemple en disant :
« Achetez les fruits et légumes,
ils sont bons, origine France,
bio, sans pesticides. »
Ces campagnes-là sont moins efficaces pour
faire évoluer la perception de qualité
que lorsqu’on fait des campagnes
sur les fruits et légumes
en racontant des jolies histoires autour.
Dans le premier cas,
on est capable de faire évoluer la
perception de qualité de quatre points.
Dans le deuxième cas, de treize points.
Là aussi, c’est encore très étonnant.
Alors comment est-ce qu’on explique
ce qu’on a vu tout à l’heure
dans la publicité ?
C'est très simple.
Il y a peut-être de nombreux mécanismes
à l’œuvre dans ce genre de situations,
mais il y a un mécanisme qui
explique particulièrement bien
pourquoi argumenter
est souvent moins efficace
que ne pas argumenter dans une publicité.
Ce mécanisme s’appelle
effectivement la réactance.
Découverte à la fin des années 60 par deux
chercheurs, Jacques et Sharon Brahim,
la réactance est en fait
un mécanisme de défense, de réaction.
De défense psychologique que
nous mettons en œuvre en nous,
plus ou moins consciemment,
quand nous avons le sentiment
que notre liberté est en danger.
Or, lorsque vous cherchez à convaincre
quelqu’un, à faire évoluer ses opinions,
en argumentant sans relâche,
vous lui donnez l’impression
d’enfreindre sa liberté.
De nombreuses études passionnantes
ont prouvé effectivement
qu’inciter fortement un individu
à choisir un comportement A
stimulait chez cet individu
l’envie de choisir un comportement B.
Et les chercheurs sont
même parvenus à démontrer
que cette réactance est présente en nous
dès l’âge de deux ou trois ans.
Comment s’y sont-ils pris ?
Les chercheurs ont disposé dans une pièce
des jouets pour enfants
avec deux espaces.
D’un côté, des jouets
tout à fait accessibles,
d’un autre des jouets rendus
inaccessibles au moyen d’une barrière.
Que s’est-il passé ?
Les enfants ont, presque systématiquement,
voulu jouer avec les jouets
rendus inaccessibles.
C'est humain.
Cet enfant qui cherche
à défendre et maintenir sa liberté
est présent en nous toute notre vie.
Vous pouvez l'observer autour de vous,
dans votre quotidien.
Et surtout sur vous-même.
La réactance,
c’est quand
vous allez au restaurant,
on vous propose une table
et vous avez subitement envie
de vous asseoir à une autre.
La réactance, c’est quand,
à l’école primaire,
vous détestiez être assis
tout le temps à la même place,
mais qu’à la fac, vous détestiez
qu’on pique la place
à laquelle vous aviez
l’habitude de vous asseoir.
La réactance, c’est
quand vous vous rendez compte
que vous ne détestez pas
faire des tâches ménagères
et que vous détestez
qu’on vous le demande.
Que vous débarrassez
avec plaisir chez les amis,
mais que vous faites tout
pour ne pas le faire chez vous.
Et puis la réactance, c’est quand en 2020,
vous voulez absolument vous fournir en
masques pour vous protéger du virus
mais qu’un an après,
vous ne vouliez plus les porter
quand ils deviennent obligatoires.
C’est exactement ça, la réactance.
Et c’est là qu’on voit que
la réactance peut devenir parfois
à l’origine de mouvements de masse.
Il y a un effet qu’on remarque
parfois dans l’actualité,
un effet qui est directement
lié à la réactance.
Cet effet, c'est l'effet Streisand.
Vous en avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler.
L’effet Streisand consiste à l’explosion
médiatique, à la viralité,
d’un objet ou d’un phénomène
qu’on a voulu censurer.
Et ça arrive tous les jours.
Vous souvenez-vous de cette photo ?
(Rires)
En septembre 2013, l’AFP publie,
puis retire de sa base de données
immédiatement cette photo.
Trop tard.
Cette censure est perçue
comme un abandon de la liberté.
Des internautes qui possèdent cette photo
font alors tout pour la diffuser
et toutes les personnes qui ne l’ont
pas vue ont envie d’y avoir accès.
Le mécanisme est clair :
censure, réactance,
rétablissement de ma liberté.
Et c'est ce qu'on observe tous les jours.
La manière dont
le journalisme d’investigation
utilise aussi cette technique, parfois
inconsciemment, est aussi passionnante.
Que ce soit les Panama Papers
ou les Macron Leaks,
toutes ces enquêtes qui reposent
sur de la fuite d’informations
disent à votre cerveau que
vous pourriez avoir accès
à des informations
auxquelles vous ne devriez
pas avoir accès.
Cela rend ces informations
complètement irrésistibles.
Et c’est d’ailleurs là qu’on voit
à quel point la réactance peut
devenir un outil de manipulation.
Et c'est là qu'il faut s'en méfier.
La manière dont les partis extrêmes
ou les propagateurs de fausses infos,
notamment sur les plates-formes sociales
utilisent la réactance au quotidien
doit nous alerter.
Elles le font parfois en vous disant :
voici toutes les infos confidentielles
qu’on sait sur tel homme politique
ou sur telle entreprise.
Ou alors parfois des hommes
politiques vont sur des plateaux
ou s’expriment sur Internet
en vous disant :
« On tente de me censurer,
rétablissez ma liberté. »
En réalité, tous ces contenus-là
reposent sur la réactance et tentent
d’obtenir à la fois votre attention
et votre adhésion
en reposant sur ce mécanisme psychologique
qui est aujourd’hui bien connu.
On se rend compte alors que
la réactance est un formidable outil
pour maintenir notre liberté.
Mais c’est aussi un outil
de manipulation redoutable
lorsqu’il est aux mains
de personnes, d’entreprises
ou de partis politiques malintentionnés.
Ce que je voulais partager
avec vous ce soir,
c’est alors une invitation
à vous interroger et à vous alerter
quand vous êtes face
à des mécanismes de réactance.
Alors, désormais, alertez-vous.
Alertez-vous quand, dans votre quotidien,
une personne tente
d’obtenir votre attention
avec une information
supposée être confidentielle.
Alertez-vous
lorsqu’un parti politique ou une
personne tente d’obtenir votre attention
en vous disant qu’elle est
systématiquement censurée.
Et surtout alertez-vous
lorsqu’une personne vous dit :
« Je ne cherche pas à te convaincre. »
C’est probablement qu’elle est en train
de franchir la barrière de la réactance.
Merci.
(Applaudissements).
Bravo !